here that we have a struggle against an
enemy to vanquish whom is really to
suffer defeat where victory in one
consciousness is really lost in its
opposite consciousness of life of its
existence and activity is only in
agonizing over this existence and
activity for therein it is conscious
that its essence is on its opposite is
conscious only of its own nothingness
raising itself out of this consciousness
it goes over into the unchangeable but
this elevation is itself this same
consciousness it is therefore directly
consciousness of the opposite that is of
itself as a particular individual the
unchangeable that enters into
consciousness is through this very fact
at the same time affected by
individuality and is only present with
the latter individuality instead of
having been extinguished in the
consciousness of the unchangeable only
continues to arise therefrom
in paragraph 209 Hegel is bringing to a
close the sort of tumult and confusion
that has been going on in the last two
paragraphs he is tying it to a kind of
knot you might say and he's using this
very interesting imagery of the battle
that one simply cannot win
why not he says that it's a struggle a
come with with an enemy a find an
adversary right and unlike other battles
with enemies or adversaries where if you
put forth the effort you can hopefully
defeat them or at least keep them at bay
in this case there is a weird
reciprocity going on because like he
says to Van the to van mushroom is
really to suffer defeat so when you
attain the victory you really are
defeated yourself your Clausing yourself
to lose already a little weird right
where victory in one consciousness is
really lost in its opposite so success
equals failure and likewise failure you
could say perhaps you know reciprocally
equals success in some weird way and
we're going to see that happen here
what's going on well we have these two
consciousnesses remember we have the
contingent consciousness and then the
consciousness or of the unchangeable the
eternal or perhaps we have to call it
the eternal consciousness right and both
of these are really what consciousness
is but it's lost sight of the fact that
it really is both of these and the
relationship between them what is
mediated them and they're sort of going
off at the Antipodes sort of like some
sort of mechanism that has broken down
and ceased to be a unity and now he has
competing parts and they're trying to
figure out how they're going to align
with each other so the transformation
that's going to begin here
in paragraph 209 it is really extremely
important it has to do with what we
might call a recuperation of
individuality Hegel is going to be
working this through quite a bit in the
paragraphs that come so he starts off by
talking about consciousness of life and
here what he means is the contingent
consciousness consciousness of life of
its essence its existence and activity
what do we mean there we mean that
day-to-day preoccupation with who am i
and and what do I have to do and what
does it mean for me to actually exist or
to to have of someplace you know to be
somewhere you could say and why do I
talk about life here well life is as
we've seen in so many places this sort
of proliferation into all sorts of
contingent shapes so many that it
becomes difficult even to really
generalize about life we saw that life
starts to escape the generalizations
about it in at least Hegel system
doesn't it so he says that we are as an
individual involved with consciousness
of our own existence and consciousness
the activities that we are involved in
but then it goes a little bit further
and it talks about agonizing over this
why do we agonize over our existence
well in part because we've realized that
there's something bigger than us that at
least at this point in time we don't
feel connected with and we feel is
somehow beyond us it's taken up the
meaning of life and so what about our
core life the stuff that we're doing or
the very fact that we exist does it mean
anything does it doesn't have any value
any importance so he says it becomes
conscious that its essence is only its
opposite
what is its opposite in a certain sense
its opposite as the
changeable but if we're focusing solely
on the individual in the light of the
unchangeable its opposite is also
nothingness this is becoming conscious
of the not only contingency but the fact
that contingency in a certain sense
signifies nothing signifies nothingness
signifies a lack of value a lack of
importance of lack of determinacy
ironically by beating determinate one
loses the very sense of what that
determinacy means or matters so what is
what is a possible movement beyond this
is there any way out of what looks to be
an impasse where the individual is just
stuck here stewing in its own
conceptions and saying oh my life
doesn't matter at all my activities
whatever they happen to be they are
meaningless they amount to nothing
something that we will often do indeed
experience he talks about it raises
itself out of this consciousness the
consciousness the agonizing
consciousness here right
raising itself out of this consciousness
it goes over to the unchangeable and it
looks at the unchangeable as something
that really does have meaning that does
have value that does have importance
that is going to last beyond the the
life of the individual this is what does
this handle you know people do this in
all sorts of ways when they start
thinking about what is my legacy
this is kind of a digression but it's
worth thinking about being in terms of
this this passage when a person thinks
about their legacy they typically say
what am i leaving behind all right and
they tend to focus on achievements
achievements are things that our
activities bring about or they focus on
the example that they left their
existence and their activities right or
are they focused on something
a bit more vague you know I improved by
my city I left behind children who are
well raised that's all very well and
good but why does that legacy matter I
mean think about this if you're leaving
behind it will take children for an
example so you raised some good children
or you were a teacher you raised you
elevated some great students to the
level of being professors themselves
well who cares I mean what is their
value well they had some great students
as well
and then you had some great students as
well and pretty soon if you do that long
enough you start to see that this chain
is just a chain of things that
ultimately don't have value and purpose
in and of themselves but only in
relation to something else
so for example Socrates why did Socrates
matter coming into being and the
activities that engage him well he was
the teacher of Plato and Plato was the
teacher of Aristotle is the sort of
stuff we tell each other in history
books and when we do preliminary
lectures right and then Aristotle why I
don't remember who he chocolate well
it's a fine fellow frost us and then
people like they don't move and you
start to see that it doesn't really
matter unless there's something
intrinsic that these guys connect it up
with what is that that's something
eternal something unchangeable so we
lose ourselves in the unchangeable now
the Hegel has in mind here not so much
thinking about buildings or philosophies
but rather things that our greatest
spirits into a kind of religious
attitude but a religious attitude is an
attitude about things that have ultimate
meaning or purpose or that matter that
ground everything else and that's what
the unchangeable is do it here
all right so the individual wants to get
away from this
by losing itself in something that is
indeed larger than itself so he says it
goes over into the unchangeable but this
elevation is it is itself this same
consciousness it can't completely leave
this behind and the unchangeable kids
and be also consciousness because this
whole thing is of course consciousness
right so he goes on and he says it is
therefore directly consciousness of the
opposite what is consciousness of the
opposite the unchangeable the
unchangeable is consciousness of
individuality well what else would be
the what else would the unchangeable be
consciousness of I mean it could be
thought thinking itself sure but
whenever we conceive of something like
you know my god it's also thinking all
the individual things isn't it unless
it's an epicurean God which in case it
doesn't care about that sort of stuff
but even the epicurean gods presumably
care about some particulars
individuality matters to it now it's not
clear at this point in this paragraph
how individuality is going to enter in
here but he says it is consciousness of
its opposite of itself the unchangeable
as a particular individual the
unchangeable that enters into
consciousness entering back into the
consciousness of the individual person
is through this very fact at the same
time affected by individuality
it is only he point only presents with
the latter meaning it only has presence
in the world in consciousness to the
individual this this this unchangeable
enters into
engine world through taking on
individuality itself so he says in what
is the problem here
well this individuality over here wanted
to lose itself in the unchangeable and
it finds that it can't get away from
individuality
now it's actually happiness managed to
multiply individuality because the very
place that it was trying to go in order
to escape individuality turns out to be
shot through with individuality and to
present itself to consciousness as an
individual so you know we go back to
well why was this victory he lost why
was this success a defeat
it was trying to get away from its own
individuality which it found wanting it
found lacking is being threatened with
being thrown into nothingness being
being meaningless right and now it's got
just another individual on the scene
which makes things even more complicated
in this movement however consciousness
experiences justice an emergence of
individuality in the unchangeable and of
the unchangeable and individuality
consciousness becomes aware of
individuality in general in the
unchangeable and at the same time of its
own individuality in the latter for the
truth of this movement is just the
oneness of this dual consciousness this
unity however in the first instance
becomes for it one in which the
difference of both is still the dominant
feature thus there exists for
consciousness three different ways in
which individuality is linked with the
unchangeable firstly it again appears to
itself as opposed to the unchangeable
and is thrown back to the beginning of
the struggle which is throughout the
element in which the whole relationship
subsists secondly consciousness learns
that individuality belongs to the
unchangeable itself so that it assumes
the form of into it individuality into
which the entire mode of existence
passes thirdly it finds its own self as
this particular individual in the
unchangeable the first unchangeable it
knows only as the alien being who passes
judgment on the particular individual
sense secondly the unchangeable is a
form of individuality like itself
consciousness becomes thirdly spirit and
experiences the joy of finding itself
therein and becomes aware of the
reconciliation of its individuality with
the end with the universal
in section 209 we attained the
understanding that the unchangeable the
eternal the the universal is not so
simply cut off from the particular the
unit the individual a contingent yeah as
one would believe that it actually
contains individuality in a certain way
with it or that it becomes individual
individuated as its way of really being
actual and present section 210 is going
to tell us about how this plays itself
out and Hegel is going to give us a kind
of schema here the progression you know
as usual with Hegel he really does like
threes and we're gonna see three steps
to this in which you know if you want to
read thesis and to the social synthesis
you can but it's really a little bit
more complex than that because it's
really about the antithesis that are
going on and how they how they play
themselves out so he starts out by
saying that that consciousness is he
says consciousness experiences the
emergence of individuality on the in the
unchangeable now that that word
experience is important right we've seen
what that means for Hegel in the past so
keep that in mind as we go through this
he says you know the unchangeable in
individuality so there's there's the
unchangeable includes individuality in
some way right and the the individuality
is somehow connected with the
unchangeable and we're going to see
exactly how in just a minute
so he says consciousness becomes aware
of individuality in general not simply
individuality as totally particular
absolutely contingent of them we are
going to see some of that get taken up
later on in other paragraphs and also in
the religion section but consciousness
becomes aware of what we
individuality in general within the
unchangeable that means that the
unchangeable is in a certain sense
humanized that it's this is a humano
centric view of things not a view where
the the unchangeable is totally cold and
distant from humanity entirely although
that is one possibility as we're going
to see so I should hold that that for a
moment now what else he says it also
becomes aware of its own individuality
and the latter meaning in the
unchangeable so the question is when
individuality becomes aware of the
unchangeable within it not just the
unchangeable within as well I'm thinking
about God or eternity or the dialectical
process or whatever but let's say is
some important but we realized that the
unchangeable is a certain sense
connecting up with our own personality
our own crazy individuality what does
that mean for us that's part of what
Hegel is exploring here now he goes on a
little bit more and he says you know
consciousness is actually a unity but it
doesn't it doesn't yet realize this
unity because it's placing the emphasis
not on the unity but upon the
differences upon these two things as
being unequal to each other as being
disconnected as being unrelated but now
we're seeing these relations start to
coalesce and come to light this is doing
phenomenology right this is allowing the
phenomena to show themselves as they are
willing to unpack what they've got
within them so this is going to leave
Hegel now to say thus there exists for
consciousness three different ways in
which individuality is linked with the
unchangeable that's pretty important now
he's going to tell us three
possibilities for in
ooh allottee and the eternal in
consciousness and each one of them think
about it like you know door number one
door number two door number three
they're each going to go someplace one
of them is actually going to lead you
right back to the start that's the first
one individuality as merely opposed to
the unchangeable he says it appears to
itself as opposed to the unchangeable
and it's thrown back to the beginning of
the struggle which is throughout the
element in which the whole relationship
subsists so we can have all sorts of
ways of understanding the unchangeable
or if you like better the transcendent
the universal that which matters and so
long as the individual doesn't see him
or herself at all in it and doesn't see
any sort of agency or or you know
personality coming through on the part
of the the universal it's just one thing
after another and you can go from one
you know we might think about this in
terms of like a dumb Idol you can get
yet another one you know if the the
thing that you set up as you know God or
whatever it is that you want to you know
say is super important just has this
sort of mute relationship with you or a
relationship where it's totally on high
and tells you this is what you must do
and you just unquestionably obey you can
shift from one to another to another of
these pretty easily and then we do see
this indeed happening with some forms of
worship or you know what we might say
certain forms of lottery right you know
lottery a service so for example a
person what we see this quite a lot on a
person has a staunch Lee you know
Christian viewpoint that some people
would call fundamentalist although the
fundamentalists are actually a pretty
small group let's say a biblical
literalist who you know has been told
that reason is not something that we
want to use science and religion are
totally opposed to
each other you know you're going to live
in a certain way according to purity
codes and you know just keep piling
things and things up with that very very
conservative background what we call
conservative these days and when they
lose that they often swing way over to
the other extreme and become just as
rabid of a secularist and you know
hardcore atheist maybe it's not of the
sort of thoughtful variety who can
actually carry out a discussion with
somebody who isn't an atheist equally
convinced but somebody who's a crusader
I have to go for being one kind of
Crusader
to another kind of Crusader and why for
the greater glory of God science what'll
it be next self-improvement after they
abandon that then it might be the nation
that it might be the dialectical process
of materialism than it might be who
knows right but I mean one of those
compartments just leads us back to the
same place and the same problematic it's
not a dialectical advance so if you want
to call it a thesis you can because you
when you see the three things but it's
not really a thesis it's actually
already a dialectical process rolled up
in their individuality as opposed to the
unchangeable which is really imposing
itself to the individual one is the
second possibility individuality
actually belongs to the unchangeable
which assumes individuality the eternal
enters into time the eternal we might
say as a face the universal becomes
something that can stand over against us
not as a universal but is another
individual that's something very very
different isn't it that's an advanced as
far as Hegel is concerned in the
dialectical process he goes how many
says in this consciousness learn as an
individuality belongs to the
unchangeable itself it is
the essence of the unchangeable so the
person who is at this stage or the
culture that's at this stage doesn't
really understand fully what the
unchangeable is because the unchangeable
contains its opposite with itself that
is individuality right so it assumes the
form of individuality why because that
is that is that into which the entire
mode of existence passes individuality
allows it to be present allows it to be
actual allows it to appear allows it to
show forth allows it to have an agency
use that in the end of the story
that's door number two right that's all
door number two looks better than door
number three door number one sorry door
number three it is better yet thirdly
consciousness finds its own self as this
particular individual in the
unchangeable that is something very
different than finding out that the
unchangeable or the eternal where the
universal is also an individual finding
that I myself and somehow already in the
universal other questions how am i
that's going to be worked out through
much of the rest of the book right but
he says I find myself I find my own self
my true self what I really am now he
really is contingent bag of you know
meat and bones and sinews and you know
wearing this tie that I happen to have
bought and such in such a place holding
this book in my hands and blah blah blah
blah blah all these contingent things
that don't really matter rather I find
my genuine itself in the unchangeable
how that happens it's that still he had
to be clarified he told us a bit more
about this as well he says the first
unchangeable how does the
know it and as the alien being who
passes judgment on the particular
individual the alien being who compels
obedience the alien being who says thou
shalt and thou shalt not and then if you
ask what are you ii y-you know says
you're in trouble that this is going to
secure permanent record and the record
is an eternal one not just merely a
permanent one in human stands so that's
not going to be a particularly developed
conception of the the divine or the
universal and it doesn't have to be a
god it could be you know the state being
treated in that way to the state as the
judge thinking about a totalitarian
society that's part of what would be
going on in there's there's a quasi
religious attitude in every totalitarian
society because of universality what
about the second one Hegel tells us in
the second case the unchangeable is a
form of individuality like itself right
and so we become confronted by another
individual who however is a universal
individual or is a eternal individual
that will get clarified a little bit
more as we go out as well here's the
really interesting part towards the end
thirdly consciousness becomes spirit
why does this matter what is it this is
a phenomenology of spirit the
phenomenology of Geist the way in which
spirit shows itself in its development
this is where development is really
heading towards and taking place and so
he says consciousness finds itself there
as spirits and experiences the joy of
finding itself therein now just you know
speculatively finding itself therein it
experiences an affective response and
not just an affective response it's a
service level thing or you know mood
coloring the the you know attitude it's
running throughout the entire person
when a person truly feels joy it is an
entire response right so it becomes
aware in this of the reconciliation of
its individuality with the universal and
what does that mean a reconciliation and
overcoming the estrangement you remember
we said that consciousness does not yet
realize that it is the one who is
introducing this split and the one
that's emphasizing the differences
reconciliation is what takes us beyond
these differences and reunites
everything and doesn't just reunited in
a purely let's put things together away
this is for a consciousness
consciousness becomes conscious of the
reconciliation
you